did you throw out your neck watching the
movie not this movie yeah I watched uh
this was when Borat came yeah yep
Charlize Theron injured herself while
watching Borat
I had a pre-existing injury in my neck
I'd herniated disc I'm a mess
I had a herniated disc in my neck and a
few of us went to go and see Borat and
halfway through that movie I laughed so
hard that I that I oh my neck locked up
and like an ambulance had to take me to
the hospital and I was in the hospital
for five days my god and I have I didn't
finish the movie I've never like fully
finished the movie it's a risk now
Charlie's told the story on The Late
Night with Seth Meyers while promoting
her own politically minded comedy long
shot do it fate I mean who wants to
follow me around the world I know if I
have five minutes to be affectionate
yeah now Charlize has done a lot of
movies but this is her first ever
romantic comedy I don't think it's that
easy to make these movies and so people
are trying to make yeah apparently
comedies prove more difficult to film
than any of chartres Lisa's action
movies in fact Charlie says she's only
ever injured herself while making
comedies this is so stupid we had to do
a small little action thing like a tiny
little thing
and this really nice stunt guy wanted to
put some kneepads on me and as I sat
down just to put the kneepads on my hand
slipped and my head hit a bench behind
me and I ended up in in the ER like it
was so stupid
[Music]